j'accueille m'a planté bagnon
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir stéphane guillon vos seins revue
de presse de la semaine
bonsoir
c'est à vous pour votre revue de presse
de la semaine c'est fait j'ai des scoops
politique cette semaine chéri c'est du
béton j'ai tout piqué à la source à la
cellule d'espionnage de nicolas sarkozy
dimanche au front national on a tiré les
rois présent dieudonné a refusé de faire
balthazar
plainte dans la banlieue de montretout
un gentil doberman a promené un bipède
extrêmement dangereux sans laisse et
sans muselière
et puis
on connaît enfin l'origine des
fulgurances de françois bayrou des
bourrins les lui murmure à l'oreille
après sa plaisanterie sur le couple
royal hollande au grand journal arnaud
montebourg peaufine son sketch la madone
et le culbuto
bientôt jamel comedy club
bernard kouchner et rené souchon sont
peut-être de bon conseil mais ils ont
une haleine de book observer la main de
la candidate
une info libération ségolène et françois
font chambre à part mais que j'ai commun
c'est très sexe du partage l'agrafeuse
le taille crayon et parfois le fax à jet
d'encre
ce week-end ségolène et aux antilles
elle aurait dû y aller avec georges
frêche qui trouvent qu'il ya trop de
noirs en équipe de france comme elle
fait toujours une gaffe en déplacement
là tu l'as fait dès le départ tu gagne
du temps
un policier est puni pour avoir dormi
dans le lit présidentielle ça ne
pourrait pas arriver à sarkozy le lit
est trop petite dans les jambes pliées
t'es pas bien
société un bracelet électronique pour
retrouver les bébés enlever ou sont-ils
dans le congélateur la cheminée ou au
fond de la vologne
mais mais toujours ouverture d'un resto
du coeur pour les nourrissons j'espère
que patrick fiori ne va pas chanter ou
encore savent alors ayez fait métaux
petit comme ça ça les flingues
médecine après une deuxième greffe du
visage réussie nouvel exploit pour
l'équipe du professeur lantieri une
actrice d'environ 60 ans s'est fait
greffer le corps d'une jeune fille de 17
ans réel dombasle c'est son nom
les mac h les cicatrices faut que ça
sèche
[Rires]
on passe à table
[Applaudissements]
télévision en france de virer son
directeur des programmes jean baptiste
jouit patrick de carolis plaident pour
une telle est stérile si tu souhaites
couper la [ __ ] des noirs tu gardes ton
poste si tu t'appelles jouit tu dégages
on jouit plus mais on s'éclate l'île de
la tentation à l'elysée le 11 février
prochain michel drucker et sa chienne
olga iront interviewé le chef de l'état
sur sa relation avec bernadette
sur tf1 claire chazal va danser au
profit d'une association
admirer la reine du 20h dans un très bel
assouplissement fessiers totalement
détendu offerte
quelques secondes plus tard philippe
torreton complétera la position
[Rires]
showbiz dalida entre dans le domaine
public une mauvaise nouvelle pour
orlando son frère à 71 ans généralement
opère sa prostate lui perça bourse
bourse toujours amanda lear
à mon avenir est élevé au rang de
chevalier des arts et des lettres
présent à la cérémonie son compagnon
manuel casella c'est la première fois
qu'un chevalier vient chercher sa
médaille avec sa monture
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
merci stéphane les corrections de ne
rien rater de in a l'habitude abonnez
vous mettez un pouce bleus